desde este coche el agresor fue
trasladado al tribunal de ansi saliendo
de la estación de policía donde estaba
detenido desde el atentado fue llevado
ante los jueces el sábado por la mañana
unas horas más tarde la fiscal anunció
oficialmente que estaba siendo
investigado
la oficina del fiscal de ansi abrió hoy
una investigación judicial sobre los
cargos de intento de asesinato y
rebelión con un arma dos jueces de
instrucción del tribunal judicial de
ansia han sido asignados al caso la
oficina del fiscal ha pedido que se ha
puesto en prisión preventiva y esta
mañana fue presentado ante dos jueces de
instrucción que lo acusaron de estos
delitos no quiso hablar con los jueces
el atacante de 31 años permaneció en
silencio durante sus 48 horas bajo
custodia policial y también ante los
magistrados encargados de la
investigación
la fiscal confirmó la ausencia de
motivación terrorista o de factores
psiquiátricos probados al menos por el
momento
el psiquiatra constató la ausencia de
elementos delirantes sin embargo
consideró prematuro hacer cualquier
valoración sobre la presencia o ausencia
de patologías psiquiátrica
durante su rueda de prensa la fiscal dio
noticias de las seis víctimas cuyas
vidas ya no corren peligro una
concentración pública está convocada en
las calles de ansi para el domingo a las
11 de la mañana en apoyo a las víctimas
y sus familias